calling a man bold counts as sexual
harassment UK judge rules UK important
tribunal argued that the use of the word
bald as an insult related to a protected
characteristic of sex calling a man ball
can now be classed as sexual harassment
a UK employment tribunal judge has ruled
this is CNBC three members of the
tribunal who decided on the ruling and
alluded to their own experience of hair
loss said that baldness was more
prevalent in men than women therefore
they argued that the use of the word
bald as an insult related to a protected
characteristic of sex the tribunal
compared calling a man bold to
commenting on the size of a woman's
breasts based on a 1995 case what do you
think is is calling a man ball the same
thing you're a small titty [__]
foreign
[__]
and it's not it's just you bald
what if they have big titties then is
that the same yeah so small titty
claiming talking about a number another
woman's breasts is the same as talking
about a man's baldness what if I say
that you've got a beautiful head of hair
you've got a big head of hair that's a
lot of hair you've got there yeah uh wow
stop sexualizing me if if we were to
consider this versus The grammarly Thing
I wonder which one's more ridiculous
this is pretty this is pretty ridiculous
this isn't yeah this is pretty pretty
story the story is really good the
ruling published Wednesday was made on a
case where the insult was alleged to
have been used against Tony Finn while
he worked as an electrician for the
British bone Manufacturing Company Finn
had worked at the company who
manufactures wooden Cask closures for
the Brewing industry in Yorkshire in the
northeast of England for nearly 24 years
it was fired last year and the
circumstances around his dismissal were
also part of the case Finn claimed that
he was called a bald
and was also threatened
Jamie King in a dispute in July 2019 the
tribunal determined that using this
insult was a violation against the
claimant's dignity it creates an
intimidating environment it was done for
that purpose and it related to The
Climate sex so
ladies and gentlemen do not call a man
bald or you will get serious trouble
I mean the the
I didn't know that's why he filed it I
mean that that's just like you're making
fun of someone on the job that's
harassment right uh I don't think saying
the word bald as a description should be
then uh
you know more specifically like tuned
into oh this is sexual harassment like
the bald part saying someone's a bald
like that's just making fun of someone
right like that's harassment of course
on the job
um
what that's that's what they said but
the problem the problem is that if you
want to do protected sex characteristics
you're going to open up these kinds of
conversations right because on average
women don't go bold that much so it
means that men will take their boldness
as a protected characteristic it's the
same reason why oh so now we're
factoring averages and generalizations I
think so but I don't think we I don't
think people want to do that that often
do they
I saw a really interesting post on
Instagram yesterday about the fact that
calling someone uh an incel or a virgin
or a cook online is significantly more
accepted than [__] shaming if you were
to call a girl on social media a [__] or
a [__] that would go down very badly
but if you were to accuse a guy of being
a virgin that would just be seen as a a
quippy insult so there are asymmetries
in what is typically used and what's
typically accepted I think and uh yeah
ball Glides matter man but in think in a
world where we're not allowed to make
rules based off of generalizations right
where we have to factor in every little
specific thing you are now making a rule
based off of a generalization what's an
example that we're not allowed to make
something based on generalization well
we have to factor in all different
genders and and Norms like we we create
rules based off of
you know uh transgenders wanting to use
different bathrooms things like that who
are this they're not
the nor they are not uh a major piece
they're they're not um they're an outlet
they're an outlier where now we're using
a general out you know a generality to
determine this rule right like men are
bald women aren't so now we have to make
this rule
it's very interesting
I I I actually think that this is
part of a just general odd trend of
people getting themselves into
situations in court where they just they
just want to get back at somebody that
they feel has aggrieved them and now
without actually realizing it you have
somehow created a precedent where
calling a man bald counts as sexual
harassment in the UK because it's a
protected sex characteristic I Americans
see things that the UK
do and we just laugh like we think it's
hilarious and the funny thing is the
opposite happens too the UK sees things
that America does and they laugh too we
just laugh at each other for the stupid
[__] that we do the stupid rules that we
come up with
is so funny I I remember you said this
to me yesterday man and I just I was
laughing so hard because it was in the
UK that's why I thought it was funny and
that for no real reason it's just like
it'll be coming for the U.S as well
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]